SPEAKER 1: It should
be no surprise
that using any cloud
resource tends to cost money.
When it comes to managing
your Google Cloud costs,
you'll want to be able to
understand what your costs are,
put controls in place
so you don't overspend,
and then optimize
your costs from there.
Let's see how you can understand
your Google Cloud costs
and optimize virtual machines
running on Compute Engine.
The best way to
understand your costs
is to use the billing reports
available in the cloud console.
Just use the left
navigation to click Billing
and choose your billing account.
Here's a quick
summary of your costs.
If you want to drill
into further detail,
choose Reports on the left side.
Here, you'll be able to see your
costs broken down by project
so you can quickly tell where
your costs are coming from.
In addition, you can
group costs by product
to see which Google Cloud
services are making up
your costs.
And then filter by SKU to
see a more detailed breakdown
of your usage.
So that's how you
can get a better
understanding of your costs.
Now let's look at some
ways to optimize your costs
for Compute Engine.
Compute Engine automatically
applies discounts
for running a virtual machine
over a sustained period
of time.
These are called
sustained use discounts
and don't require any
configuration to enable.
You can save up to 30% on
a virtual machine running
during a significant portion
of the billing month.
If you know that you'll
be using resources
over a long period of time,
you can save even more
by using committed
use discounts.
These are great for
static workloads where
you have consistent resource
usage, like multiple production
machines.
To see what your usage looks
like, head to the Commitments
tab on the left navigation.
Here, you can see how many
compute resources you're
using, like VCU cores,
RAM, local SSD, or GPUs.
If there's a certain amount
you know that you'll always
be running, such
as a baseline, you
may want to sign up for
commitments for a one or three
year term, which can
save you up to 57%.
Here, for example, you can see
that this graph is pretty flat.
So there's not a lot of
fluctuation in the amount
of resources being consumed.
This would make for a great
candidate for purchasing
commitments to save money.
In addition, commitments can
be made per project or span
across an entire
billing account.
So you can set up the
scope that makes the most
sense for your organization.
If you want to
ensure that you're
maximizing the
commitments you have
and the potential cost
savings that you could have,
the committed use
discount analysis report
is the best place to start.
If you actually want to
purchase a commitment,
head to the compute page and
click on Purchase Commitment
to get started.
Coming soon are
automatic recommendations
for your committed use discounts
based on your historical usage.
Applying these recommendations
can provide an easy way
to save on long term usage.
But if you have spiky
or dynamic workloads,
there are other ways
to save on your costs
that you should consider.
To start, Google
Cloud automatically
provides recommendations
for machines and disks
that may be idle
or underutilized.
In the recommendation
column, you
can see suggestions for each VM
based on its historic resource
usage, such as adding or
removing resources or even
deleting them entirely.
Thanks to the ability to resize
your VMs to custom machine
sizes, you can fine
tune your workloads
to be exactly the right size
and not pay for any resources
that you're not using.
If your machines are
already the right size,
but there are times when
you don't need them,
you can also stop the
instances to save money.
When a VM is stopped, you
don't pay for the Cores or RAM
running.
For example, you may be
running a test environment
that you don't need outside
of core business hours.
So it can be shut off.
You can even use some quick
Cloud Functions code and Cloud
Scheduler to turn your VMs
on and off automatically
when you do or don't need them.
Depending on the type of
workload you're running,
you may also benefit from using
different types of instances
and pre-emptable VMs.
The newer generation of E2
general purpose machines
can give you similar
performance to the N1 series
while also saving you money.
In addition, memory
optimized and compute
optimized instances may be
better fits for your machines,
letting you focus in on exactly
those resources that you need.
Leveraging
pre-emptable instances
is a great way to run stateless
workloads that aren't time
sensitive, like genomics
or media transcoding.
They have a maximum
uptime of up to 24 hours
before they're deleted,
but they're 80% cheaper.
You can choose pre-emptable when
making a new compute instance,
but you'll likely
want to automate this
by spinning up new pre-emptable
machines when you need them.
Every workload is different.
So it's important to understand
what your resource uses looks
like and which tools you can
use to optimize your costs based
on your unique needs.
Start with the billing reports
to understand your costs.
And then see which of
these recommendations
works best for you.
Check out this link to see
videos and documentation
about more ways to manage
and optimize your costs.